foreign
[Music]
hello
interesting
hey folks like the earrings my kiddo
picked these out for me
years ago
but uh but I quite like them
hope everybody is doing well
um I'm not surprised you can't Name That
Tune Stephen I'll be very curious if
anyone
could name that tune it is not good it
is not good Omens
uh Pirates
but
solid gas
good guess but wrong
what's happening in Germany with
transphobia I don't know
I am afraid to find out
all right so ham
dude
uh Pirates
I heard that you got an A in your summer
class that's fantastic hope everything
keeps going in a great direction for
that
are we rolling
you weren't listening to the jump gate
you feel a sign
um so reminder while I will try and keep
up with the chat as we are live
um I make no promises that I am able to
get to chats that do not come with a
super chat
um so I will still try and guess up
that's the one thing that guarantees it
plus you get the heart of appreciation
from me so you know there's that
hmm
Charles martinet is retiring
I know that name but I don't know why I
know that name
new self-proposed self-id law is
supposed to include a government
database of all trans people oh
oh [__] off
[__] all the way off
you know what
of all countries that should know better
than to have a database of minorities
it should be Germany and I don't like to
like hold something from 80 years ago
against the people that are currently
there but like what the heck
oh
good grief hey Meg it's good to see you
what are the plans when the prisoner is
over
um I don't want to say because I don't
want people to get excited for that as
opposed to the return of jump gate we
will talk about what will happen after
The Prisoner if it is still necessary
for us to not talk about Babylon 5 after
The Prisoner we will see whether or not
that is the case
oh Mario's voice actor
right Charles martinid that's right
I could take over that job
it's a me Mario
I can do that
what am I eating
Peach
I could eat a peach for hours
[Music]
okay
German uh trans and leftist Twitter has
been agreeing with you we do not want
good
ah
what I consider myself an influencer I
mean I I tend to prefer to call myself a
content creator instead of an influencer
because
when most people think influencer they
think people who like get a bunch of
brand deals and like get paid to go and
go like oh look where I am now fam and
like and that's not what I do but like
if you're not going to accept the term
content creator because it's too broad
then yeah what I do is probably close to
the influencer
uh then most other descriptors you can
come up with
uh
peaches peaches peaches peaches peaches
peaches Peach that's something saying
that
Waluigi is my favorite voice solid pick
I don't know him as well
because he kind of got introduced after
I had started to fade on a lot of stuff
I don't
I don't even know if I've played any of
the
Mario Kart games he's in
I mean I know he does the Wayne
I know he's got that
but
no Peter I am not I have no interest in
Ahsoka I don't know her as a character
and none of the trailers have done
anything for me I do not intend to watch
that
so do I use doordash never have no
what I consider you an influencer
I don't know who are you trying to
influence
have I listened to flamey Grant
I don't know who or what that is
so let's go with new
Aaron thank you for the Super Chat that
is very generous
thank you nothing exciting to say hello
just wanted to get a super chatted well
it is greatly appreciated and thank you
for oil on top of it much appreciated
uh no uh Harriet I Harriet uh Amidala I
still have not seen del Toro's Pinocchio
it's on the to-do list with a bunch of
other stuff
regular senses still exists yeah like
the things that actually should matter
in terms of like demographic information
are covered by the census you don't need
to
um
freaking database of trans
I'm watching Colombo he's so oh
Colombo's great yeah propaganda all that
I know I still like some cop stuff I
can't help it but yeah I do like Colombo
uh just one more question
I enjoyed your prisoner recap the oh
I'm glad that Jesse and I are
alternating on doing the synopsis for
those uh but oh dang
trying to trying to keep track of what
goes on in that show and convey it
anything close or at least as coherent
as the show itself is oh
I I end up with so many pages of notes
trying to recap episodes
[Music]
which do doctors have the most in common
in my humble opinion
oh
I think two and eleven have a lot in
common I will leave it at that
the only thing I've ever seen Peter
Falcon is The Princess Bride I suspect
that's true of a lot of people
like your top thank you
I like this top too
when the prisoner originally ended view
viewers were almost rioting over the
ending do not spoil any of that neither
here nor in comments on Jesse's Channel
or her Twitter somebody like left a
comment I want to return Mike you suck
shut your mouth
um
it's also on a weird Nick Cage movie
very late in his career weird Nick Cage
movie describes
two-thirds of Nick Cage's filmography as
vague
came out as non-binary
in an in-between form of non-binary and
M to F okay
I am on my journey of discovery of my
gender and sexuality your channel has
been great comfort to me oh thank you
say films
and best of luck it is a journey
and it is it is okay to
change your mind roll back go further
forward you know ending up in a
different place than where you are right
now doesn't mean that you're wrong with
where you are right now a journey is a
process so
engage with it
and I wish you the best
that's why I love Nick Cage Nick Nick
Cage is interesting I uh I will give him
that
my oldest son and I went to see Renfield
here I still haven't seen Renfield
it's called Next oh
okay I remember seeing trailers for that
yeah never saw that one I haven't
actually seen all that much of that
cages filmography come to think of it
pretty smattered experience of
the
cageness of it all
uh
ah
who are the other people in your intro
this always confused me
I have accepted at this point that I
will never stop having to answer that
Jamie I've answered it many a time I'll
answer it again
the three other people who appear in the
logo there is Liz there's Ryan there is
Paul these are people who have
previously appeared on the channel
multiple times
um and Paul and Ryan they haven't been
on the channel in a while Liz doesn't
appear on the channel anymore but these
you know they are a part of the Channel
History and I'm not going to update the
logo to remove them
I mean unless something horrible comes
out about any of them then maybe but
like just because they don't appear on
the channel anymore doesn't mean I want
to cease acknowledging them and I like
the look
I'm assuming you're reviewing them in
broadcast order yes okay so
[Music]
the next episode of the we are all pawns
podcast is gonna go into this
um as well but short version
no matter who says otherwise
there is no agreed upon correct viewing
order of the prisoner
there just isn't there are many
recommended ones there are multiple
airing orders depending on whether
you're looking at the UK airing the U.S
airing and various
um channels that aired the episodes in
their own order there is uh Blu-ray
release order there is a there is
another DVD release order all these have
the episodes in different order the only
thing that everything agrees on in terms
of the prisoner is what episode is first
and what three episodes are last
everything else in the middle keeps
getting shuffled and there are a ton of
fan orders a lot of which are based on
like contextual clues for how long it's
been except that strikes me as a really
faulty way to try and order a show like
The Prisoner given that it's surrealist
nature means it's perfectly viable that
the show could have been messing with
continuity and timeline on purpose and
you're trying to undo that is that a
certainty no it's not but I'm just
saying I have no faith in any order I
understand that the that the broadcast
order is probably not the ideal order
but there is no fan consensus on what
the ideal order is unlike say Babylon 5
which has the lurkers guide which pretty
much all fans agree on
so
that is yeah that is one of the things
that has to be dealt with uh when
talking about the prisoner
Nick Cage needs to play a detective in a
parody of 40s noir films maybe directed
by Ryan Johnson he was hilarious and
Spider-Man Noir uh you want to see an
interesting take of him as a detective
you should check out
um
Bad Lieutenant Port of Call New Orleans
probably not exactly what you're looking
for but it's a thing
am I going to watch poor things I'm glad
there's trippy sci-fi that I can watch
to break from Doctor Who in MCU I
do not know what poor things is
so
I don't know I would have to be educated
on what the heck it is
do I watch any animation critics yeah
few
cell specs is the main one that I watch
but I mean I watch other critics who
talk animation but aren't necessarily
exclusive uh on it
I've I've gotten turned off I'm not
going to name names but I've gotten
turned off to some animation channels in
the past because they can get
really bizarrely judgmental over
people's tastes and like any critical
channel can but like it it
when animation critics get judgmental it
it hits different with me for some
reason I don't know if it's them or me
but
excuse me
uh not a fan of Mick cage but I love
that other guy in Renfield he plays
Peter in the uh great I love that show
oh yeah Nicholas Holt he's good stuff
um
uh
kind of Dharma yeah kinda here's the
thing
uh I understand that it is a quote from
the show that appears in most episodes
it's part of the opening sequence uh
it's kind of a spoiler to draw attention
to it
so yeah
I'm late forget to take you forget to
take you with me to lunch oh well uh
what's for lunch Laura
before doing the prisoner Patrick mcguin
was totally not James Bond secret agent
John Drake Drake John Drake No really in
danger man yeah I know about that I've
never seen any of those
Supremo Mega
is in the chat hello there my friend on
Whedon
one grade of criticism I have is that
none of his characters are allowed to
have surviving stable relationship uh
does that also bother you
I mean yeah it
it bothers me more looking at the full
scope of his work than in any one show
if that makes sense
um I think
so like where it tends to really bother
me that nobody has a stable relationship
is comic books but it's not just because
there's no stable relationships it's
because it's something like Marvel or DC
you are dealing with hundreds of
characters and decades
decades worth of material and you can't
manage to have one stable freaking
relationship that you don't end up
killing one of them in or one of them
turns evil or you claim it stable
because they never got divorced but
they're actually really toxic
like
it really bothers me there because those
worlds are so expansive and so devoid of
a stable relationship in the in
something like Buffy or angel or Firefly
I'm a little bit more con
um a little bit more forgiving uh with
each of those isolated incidents because
with these people at the point in their
lives that the show was talking about
the instability makes a bit more sense
or it fits characters or I'm not having
to see it over the course of decades and
nobody can hold it together
so you know
his Show's topped out at seven seasons
and I would say that Buffy by the end
was kind of pushing it
but
I I do think
um that what really irks me is is a
pattern over an entire career so when I
look at the entirety of whedon's work
yeah kind of annoying
um especially considering he wasn't even
bad at writing couples
like he could do it fine I don't uh
whatever
um
but yeah no it it's I don't love it but
it I don't find it super egregious with
him
Joshua reminds me heavily of Rick Berman
both used the show run extremely
successful in love shows and were
extremely problematic but I think like
Berman whedon's work was carried by
others I don't think that's a fair
comparison because Rick Berman didn't
even want to do Star Wars sorry Star
Trek
like he really didn't
to him it was a job it was a job that he
you know he ran the whole thing he
didn't have a passion for the work he
didn't have a passion for the characters
Rick Berman flat out didn't care
whatever you want to say about Joss
Whedon and there's plenty to say and
I've said most of it uh the man did care
you know you can say that his work was
carried by others by the actors by other
writers Etc and like they certainly
contributed and it's a lot easier to
focus in on their contributions now that
we don't really want to praise Whedon
but those shows wouldn't exist at all
without him
Star Trek would have existed without
Berman
it didn't need him to exist it could
have been somebody else
so I don't I don't feel comfortable with
that comparison just because of the
nature of
their necessity of the thing even
existing at all if that makes sense
I had everyone from the UK have a good
have a good evening be seeing you
uh
see
my anxiety has been bad today I told
someone I support on patreon YouTuber uh
YouTuber he likes might have made some
Pro great replacement comments
he said your interpretation is beyond
bad faith
I mean that's a hard thing to hear
obviously without knowing either the
person who you talk to nor the YouTuber
you refer to I am not in a position to
offer you reassurance on that because I
don't know any of it and
like I I I say this uh with no harsh
feelings meant behind it I don't have
the time to look into that
um
but
I do understand that
bringing forward something like that and
thinking that maybe they'll find this
helpful and they basically go no
no like that
that doesn't feel great I mean whether
you have anxiety or not that's just not
gonna feel good
um and having anxiety is obviously going
to exacerbate something like that so
um I hope that you're able to settle
your sense of self and and your nerves
in the near future
well I feel like I can tell you
comfortably
is the creator you spoke to
is probably not going to hold a grudge
against you for that
because I know your anxiety well I don't
know this but I know for many people
their anxiety would tell them this
person hates me now
I I don't think he hates you I think he
disagreed with you and he probably will
not remember unless specifically
reminded in a few days it's not going to
be an active thought in his head it's
not
all right
been watching I Claudius basically Game
of Thrones with 70s Doctor Who
production value but it's only one
season long and has a good ending I have
heard very good things about I Claudius
over the years never have seen it though
Star Wars Star Trek same thing yeah
right Chandler like basically
excuse me
Star Trek would have been better with
someone else than Berman well definitely
a hell of a lot sooner than he was going
from and yeah overall probably
my nails are pretty I need to redo most
of them I've got three that are
completely gone that one needs to be
replaced that one I should redo like I
got I gotta deal with these things
what do you think of philosophy
that you should always assume someone is
acting in good face unless
proven otherwise
um
I think that is
dangerously naive
the problem is
I understand the thought and the
mentality behind an operating philosophy
like that is assume everyone is acting
in good faith unless you can prove
otherwise the the thing is
you're not going to be able to vet
everyone you disagree with
like you're not you are not going to
have the time the spoons the energy or
possibly even the means to go through
their social media posts look at the
things that they've said outside of
where they are trying to engage you in a
conversation or debate and confirm for
your to your own satisfaction oh they
aren't just doing this to twist things
nobody has the time to do that and it's
not realistic to expect them to
my standard Rule and I understand that
this is not super helpful as a guideline
but for me I just trust my gut
at this point
and all I really have to back that up is
having done this for over a decade
and having
um you know in the Vera channel for even
longer than that so even before I came
out on this channel
I had the Vera Channel out there I have
been dealing with people approaching me
in good faith and in bad and while I
cannot guarantee a 100 accuracy rating I
feel really comfortable in my ability to
tell
um or at least be pretty confident as to
whether someone is engaging in good
faith or bad faith and if I'm not sure
I don't engage if it's bad faith I will
block them so I never have to deal with
them again because I do not owe you my
time and attention if it is good faith
and I have the spoons for it I will try
my best to engage if I'm unsure I'll
probably leave it but I'll tell you what
I've learned that nine times out of ten
folks who like put something on like I
don't know about that if I leave them
and like don't ban them off from
commenting on the channel or something
like that
give it a month or two they'll Circle
back around and say something that is
very clearly bad for you I'm like oh
yeah okay the mask slipped
because
going in and always assuming oh you say
that in good faith they assume so okay
left versus right debate tactics 101
real quick
they want us to assume they mean what
they say therefore they frequently don't
they often a particularly the troll
Types on the right will deliberately
construct bad misleading and accurate
and completely wild arguments because
they are counting on us to treat them as
if they are serious and if you treat
every question as if it is good faith in
some ways you are validating it as a
valid question and the worst possible
questions that could conceivably be
asked of you aren't just bad faith in
terms of the the answer that they're
trying to coax out of you and the
argument they're trying to start some
questions that come to you are bad faith
to the degree that you should not even
be validating the question being asked
because the question itself is harmful
and I know some people will balk at that
at the idea of well if people are just
asking questions some questions are not
okay to ask
it is not up for debate
was Hitler right and if someone proposes
that to you and offers it as a good
faith debate run
because even if they mean that question
in good faith in the very slim chance
that they mean that question in good
faith
to validate that as a question even
worth having a conversation about is
inherently destructive now that is
obviously probably the most extreme
example I can come up with off the top
of my head it is often not that extreme
in that clear-cut but
while I do not think we should always
assume bad faith because that makes us
overly confrontational and it risks
pushing away people who might be
persuaded to our side I do not think it
is helpful to assume everything is in
good faith
what you can do on occasion because I
have found this sometimes myself every
now and then something will be asked
likely in bad faith but even though the
person asking it in bad faith it might
still be a question that could be asked
in good faith and maybe it's worth
addressing even if you deal with it
separate from the personal ass I've had
multiple videos I've done on the Vera
Channel along those lines like answering
the question why would somebody
transition if they don't have dysphoria
pretty much every instance that I
occurred on my channel before I did a
video answering that those people asking
we're not asking in good faith they were
asking as a I dare you to change my mind
kind of thing and I did not engage with
them but I also know that there is
enough
lack of information or lack of direct
experience with trans people and with
dysphoria that there are people who are
going to ask that same question in good
faith so I did address that question as
a good faith question even though I
never engaged with those people because
I knew they specifically were not
approaching in good faith that turned
into a bit of a thing
so
do I watch drama Channel you know I hate
that stuff Miss Wicked Wolf you know I
hate that stuff no I do not
ah
or like sometimes just asking questions
is not just asking questions I mean if
the
if the way that they justify questions
that people are like what are you on
about they're like I'm just asking
questions then they're not just asking
questions the questions they're choosing
to ask are pushing a position but
anyways yes thank you for the reminder
Carolyn I'm gonna pop over to the
Discord reminder the Council of Geeks
Discord is a patreon exclusive perk two
dollars a month gets you access to the
Discord and in that Discord is a channel
where you can ask up to three questions
and it is guaranteed that I will address
them without you having to do the super
chat in here but let me deal with those
and I will be right back let's see what
we got tangent from The Prisoner which
has Patrick mcguin who is also in
Scanners do you have a favorite David
Cronenberg movie oh the thing is
Cronenberg movies are often ones that I
admire but almost never want to re-watch
favor Cronenberg movie
um
probably Naked Lunch
just for weird Factor
uh have you watched any of the Avengers
the uk60 show honor Blackman Diana Reed
Etc if so what are your thoughts I have
only ever seen Clips it seems fun
um but no I've never seen a full episode
root beer or ginger beer neither don't
like either of them don't like sodas
so
though there is
ginger in this
anyway moving along
not experiments oh boy you are the
manager slash senior partner slash head
booba of a unique platform for Content
creators who are your top three oh
I'm not gonna
all respect to the question around that
one I am not going to answer that
because I would I would sit here with my
brain cycling for half an hour and I
still wouldn't be satisfied with my
answers so I am going to respectfully
decline that question Cake or Death uh
take please
very well
give him cake
and I'll run out of cake at this rate
uh one ha when one has an idea for a
short fan fiction story which is better
a rough outline or a detailed list and
how much research should one do to quote
unquote fool the audience I do not
engage enough with fan fiction to be
able to answer this question like I I am
a fiction writer I have never been a fan
fiction writer and I've never really
engaged with fan fiction so
ah how much research should be done or
how detailed things should be I don't
know
I don't know I'm not a part of that
world in my mind like I briefly engaged
in like a little fan fiction like just
reading like back in college like for I
don't know
a week
but I quickly got turned off whenever I
came across something and I was like but
that no that's not no that's wrong so
like I don't sit well with Canon
contradictions but they're entire fan
fictions that are 100 based around the
ways in which they mess with Canon so
again I just don't know that environment
I don't know I'm not a good person to
ask
there's a footballer in the UK who was
almost prosecuted with sexual assault
but pressured his girlfriend into
dropping the charges Manchester United
uh only just gave to the pressure not to
let him back on the team after holding
him and paid suspension for ages
since 1994 every year EA has released a
football soccer game called FIFA I am
familiar and in the 2022 iteration they
opted to remove this guy as a playable
character because of the accusations if
they'd not done that do you think that
would have been a reason that boycott
the game series uh or even EA in general
I don't know if that would have been you
should be boycotting EA they are an
absolutely atrocious company and the
FIFA franchise in particular has some of
the worst and most predatory
monetization in the entire video game
sphere there are people who have spent
thousands of dollars unwittingly on that
game it it you know a lot of people
blame OverWatch for the popular
popularization of the loot box and maybe
it did but FIFA had been doing it long
before doing it harder doing it worse
and doing it more damaging there are not
sufficient
um guard rails in place most of those
games are rated okay for children to
play despite the fact that there are
gambling mechanics in it and the uh EA
puts the onus on parents to disable that
it is on by default
EA is not a good company FIFA is not a
good organization you should not be
buying those games anyway regardless
that said I understand some people are
very committed and dedicated and are
very into the
um fan environment in which this exists
or for some people it's the only game
that they buy I'm not trying to shame
anybody for that but if we're gonna get
on our high horse about EA or FIFA or
both we've got plenty of reasons to
boycott both that do not need to involve
the rest of this question
ah remember when we got talking about
American football during the stream the
other day
and how kids shouldn't play sports like
football unboxing that uh unavoidably uh
result in people getting injured how do
you feel about the fact that we make
popular video games based on Sports like
that and let kids play them I mean I
know there are games where you can like
be an assassin or kill people with
swords but I feel like those couldn't be
taken as promoting those things since
there's an understanding those things
are bad to do in the real world I think
something like Madden can be taken as
promoting football I mean
while while you'd be hard-pressed to say
something like Assassin's Creed is
promoting anything you could very easily
argue that something like Call of Duty
is
something like Call of Duty is promoting
the military
so like if we want to go down this path
we're going to be looking at a lot of
stuff that just gets removed and as
someone who while I feel the impact of
media is important and vital and I do
not think that children should be
allowed to play American football
um I understand the concern
but
I think so long as children are kept
safe from the thing while they are
children as much as I am not trying to
dismiss the argument that they have
basically been funneled through
childhood into something that they will
then commit themselves to once they
reach adulthood and they are legally
allowed to make all of their own
decisions and that itself might not be a
great thing I accept that and I
acknowledge that but at the same time I
am not comfortable drawing a line that
says adults cannot make their own
decisions
sometimes those decisions are things I
would rather they didn't make
and if it is ultimately only hurting
themselves I don't like that especially
if it potentially comes from having been
uh having this idea glorified by movies
or just Sports on television or by video
games I don't like that but ultimately
their life is theirs and it's not mine
to say what they can and can't do once
they are adults not that it's my
business to say what they can do with
their kids but it is so it's somebody's
business to say what they can do when
they are kids so
on a similar topic there's an episode of
a cartoon I used to watch not naming it
because of the strike where a girl wants
to play football has to sue the school
to get on the team and then all the guys
realize she's actually a good player do
you think the fact we now know how
dangerous the sport is kind of ruins a
story like that I mean to make a
slightly silly analogy it's like trying
to do inspiring episode of a cartoon
where girl proof she's just as good as
the guys that showing she can smoke and
drink just as much as them I don't think
that's a fair comparison because smoking
and drinking
um smoking especially
there is
almost no upside to it it is a strictly
destructive thing
um while I take great issue with
American football and the physical harm
that is involved with it
there is camaraderie there is friendship
that is formed there is sportsmanship
there are positive things to take out of
it so I don't think that comparison uh
is a fair one to make do I think knowing
how dangerous the sport is sours it a
little bit yeah potentially just like
any just like my current understanding
of the nature of the police at this
point in my life kind of Sour's most cop
movies for me but that doesn't mean I
don't want there to ever be cop movies
again like the world is complicated it
is never so straightforward as X thing
encourages bad behavior get rid of X
thing it's going to be more nuanced than
that because it has to be because if we
start treating it as black and white as
that
well that puts us in the same mindset of
the people who say drag queens are bad
band drag queens queer people are bad
bear band queer people I have my very
strong opinions as to why American
football is bad for children to play and
I don't think they should be allowed to
play it but I don't think that that
means much like with honestly here's a
weird comparison sex education I don't
think hiding it from them or overly
demonizing it is helpful
I think
shielding them from all media that shows
football in a glorious vein is not going
to be a good thing
all you do is make it taboo and enticing
that way
so like it's complicated I I am
personally of the opinion
children should not be playing this
sport
most Americans don't agree but I don't
think they need to be shielded from the
sport existing or from growing to like
it
if you don't review the 60th Doctor Who
specials as they air on the strike so
you're planning to review them after the
strike has ended so I'm not gonna fully
answer this question because I've
actually got a video coming out tomorrow
that's going to answer that pretty
directly but stay tuned come back
tomorrow that'll be answered series one
is or sorry is series one now tainted
for you to do the number of people from
that series that have sex offense
allegations made against them do you
ever plan on re-watching it it is a
little bit unfortunately those specific
characters definitely are
um it hasn't tainted the show overall
because thankfully
um nothing came out about either say
Eccleston or uh Billy Piper so
you know if if either of them had had
those kind of allegations put against
them then yeah I probably couldn't watch
series one anymore they haven't and
while it is at times uncomfortable for
me to watch certain bits certain scenes
especially given that both of the people
who had those accusations played
characters why actively really liked
um
no I I don't think it'll stop me from RE
from re-watching it in those cases it's
like it's what I it's what I will chalk
up to is just the if Factor because
sometimes regardless of whether someone
actually was convicted how much evidence
there was how much there wasn't you're
just gonna have your own personal level
of where regardless of anything else it
just feels wrong
so those two haven't exceeded my uh
Factor even though I I have that a
little bit so like I remember a couple
weeks back somebody asked about Kevin
Spacey I'm like regardless of what
happens to them in court and whether or
not he's acquitted of stuff
just seeing his face ugh I don't want to
and
that's just comfort that has nothing to
do with like a objective Judgment of
reality that's just like no personal
Comfort look don't like it
your opinion who has been the uh what
has been the longest run of good
episodes in Doctor Who for me it's
either the last six episodes of series
three or the first six episodes of
series ten oh jeez I would have to pull
up a list
um
I would
probably say that I would probably agree
with you on that first six episodes of
series 10.
um but I'm not gonna I'm not married to
that because I'm not going to take the
time to look up the full episode list
because that would eat up five minutes
at least
um have you ever played the guard the
card game flux there's a Doctor Who
version I played it once
six years ago maybe
five six years ago
I remember liking it I remember how it's
played opinion on pumpkin chocolate chip
cookies really good
they're really good my kid's mother
makes a pumpkin chocolate chip cookie
she uses like these big ass chunks of of
chocolate and she actually adds like
pumpkin pie mix into the
um into the cookie dough and they're
they're soft and they're fluffy it's
almost like a like like a little pumpkin
chocolate cake oh it's so good oh
if this is against your current rule
about movie talk uh please don't feel
frustrated answer opinion on James
Cameron's Avatar movie the first one uh
uh enjoyed it when I saw it the first
time have never rewatched it there we go
and that is the Discord and I'm back
I'm back baby
trading card games and their booster
packs gambling or no
um
no
one could argue it is gambling adjacent
um but my gut instinct on that is no I'm
not prepared to defend that view in
court Dr lunar
thank you very much for the uh Super
Chat like the Avatar that's very cute
ever heard of armored Combat League it's
a sport that uses Knight armor blunt
weapons and with team and solo
tournaments which is based on night
tournaments and medieval warfare I have
heard of things like that I have not
heard of that in specific like there's a
local group here in Vermont the name of
which I cannot recall it's something in
I think I think it's Gaelic
I think
um so I cannot remember what it is
called so like I'm aware of groups that
do that I'm not familiar with that one
in specific I'm assuming that's probably
one of the larger ones
how much should I judge someone who
still enjoys a canceled actor
I
unless they are actively defending that
person and making an argument why you
should also be okay with that actor you
shouldn't probably
um like here's the thing
as I said everyone's got their factor
and
when you have a piece of media that you
deeply love that love might run deeper
than the uh does
so
I don't think that makes you a
fundamentally bad or flawed person to
continue to like the work of that actor
or something in which that actor appears
where I will start judging somebody is
if and when they start attacking the
victims uh defending the actor to
basically anyone who will listen going
on about conspiracy saying that everyone
else should forgive them because they
have or coming up with some you know
nonsense reason why everyone should be
agreeing with that that's where yes I
will judge the hell out of you but uh
continuing to enjoy the art like here's
the thing
mildly controversial opinion
while I have very firmly said my
feelings on spending money
towards the Harry Potter franchise
in terms of people who continue to
engage with the books or movies I'm not
mad at them and I don't judge them
I will judge people who defend JK
Rowling I will judge the hell out of
them
but people who simply continue to enjoy
the work
I would rather they didn't but I get it
I'm not going to judge them for that
so there's your
there's your condensed version with
example
[Music]
I need to start saying that more often
now my uh Factor
I've actually been anxious about the
idea he hates me now all day thank you
for alleviating that assumption it
really really helped good I'm glad that
helped 255.80
uh Supreme Omega back again on South
Park
when did it start being out of touch
with the Zeitgeist because it was
relevant in the 90s and the 2000s but it
seems to age worse than the Simpsons
um
foreign
I mean the reason it fell out of the
Zeitgeist was that its initial Hook was
shock and shock is a finite resource you
can only push a taboo so many times
before everyone's like yeah we know
that's what you do I mean it's it's a
similar tract with Family Guy
um when your big appeal is like I can't
believe they did that well eventually
like even if you haven't seen everything
they might ever do you're no longer
surprised by where they're willing to go
so that was part of it I think also
there's just been a cultural shift I
think in the late 90s early 2000s the
general attitude of
all sides suck everybody's terrible
let's laugh at everyone
I think that was a very zeitgeisty
approach to life
um for a lot of folks especially around
my age to be
about it
but I think as years have gone on I'll
you know what
I will steal an observation from yasi
croshaw
um I I forget his exact words but
basically the amounts of this there was
definitely a time where being aloof or
facetious worked as a you know standard
go-to way to be and that like acting
like every everything was dumb or not
worth taking seriously or not worth
getting invested in connected with
people because that's kind of how the
world seemed for a while
but we are now in a period where we've
learned what happens to the world when
people stop giving a crap
and don't actually take positions on
anything and what happens is the World
falls into the hands of people who do
still take positions on things and do so
give a crap it turned out that they were
monsters
so
I think the
kind of um
libertarian nihilism that underscores
South Park overall has just fallen out
of favor
just as a general Outlook
do people actually like pumpkins I heard
people like pretend to like them for
Halloween well you don't just eat
pumpkin innards Robin but yeah pumpkin
is a solid flavor if you know what to do
with it
with regards to my Buffy Angel watch
through I'm at the return of drusella uh
Drew I like Drew
Drew's good stuff
uh let's see
is that a thing contents creators have
to deal with this commenter thanks I
hate them now but I actually don't
really care
yeah kind of
I've I've definitely
um
I've definitely had some commenters who
have made it very clear to me that they
hold very deep grudges
um
against me for something I said ages ago
and I think they probably partially
justify it because they think I have a
dislike for them right back but I'm just
wondering like why are you holding on to
that like you a big thing you need to
realize about the nature of content
creation all of this is really ephemeral
the streams most of the videos that we
make if you do the kind of thing that I
do
you make it you push it out you move on
to the next thing we don't
like it's probably different for like
for people like Jesse who spend weeks or
months making multi-hour think pieces
and video essays that's not what I do so
speaking for what I do I can't be super
invested in everything I say and every
interaction that I have in the comments
section or the stream because I've got
another one to do tomorrow
so yeah and that's not to say that like
I'm not invested in the streams or I'm
not invested in my work I am but I can't
dwell on it once it's done I have new
stuff to make
that's just the reality of this as a job
um Dr lunar back with another Super Chat
oh thank you oh thank you JK Rowling
gets into a debate with Gene Roddenberry
how do you see this going and would you
pay to see that
no well no I would pay to see it
depending on who the moderator is
but you left out a crucial component in
that what's the topic
because you can't just say this person
debates this person you need a topic
that they're debating over like even the
presidential campaigns you you can just
say you know this candidate you can just
say Trump versus Biden but they're
debating over policy they're debating
over the Office of the President they
have a subject to debate so you're
missing a third part that's kind of
crucial to the question
um I don't know maybe with a good
moderator
I wouldn't pay much because I don't put
a lot of stock in debates anymore
I'm too old to see the value in them
I apologize Vera if this was a question
that you've uh answered before but is
Josh Whedon also uh on your uh factor
and that you can't re-watch any of his
uh works
either like JK
I
it's definitely not to the extreme of
rolling I can tell you that for free
while I have not re-watched any of his
stuff
he's also benefited from the fact that I
don't have the time to re-watch things
anymore for fun
um I have too much stuff that I need to
do because I've been commissioned to it
to do it or like it's something I plan
to do a video on like I don't I don't do
re-watches anymore I don't have time
um but definitely compared to JK I can
just I can make it a very easy metric
the Harry Potter movies are no longer on
my movie Shelf
my Buffy and Angel box sets still are
have I rewatched them no but
um I don't feel the need to take them
down
JK Rowling's stuff and anything
associated with her despite all the work
from other people that went into it and
the love I once had for it
I don't want it in my house so while
there is a uh factor for Whedon it's
nowhere close
to to Rolling
Supreme
yeah
on classic Simpsons even though it's
rooted in the 90s it never seems to fall
out of fashion I wonder if it's because
the satire was never mean-spirited
um I mean that could be part of it
I mean the thing was The Simpsons was
just for a long time a very smartly
written show
it
while it wasn't above going for the
cheap laugh in the moment it didn't
structure its entire episodes around the
G blab it had things to say
it's and and its satire was broad enough
uh about you know this is the quote
unquote American nuclear family and
whether or not that image of a family is
still relevant it's still an image that
persists we all know what the nuclear
family is even if the relevance of that
model is fading we still understand it
as a touch Point therefore a show that
parodies and plays with those Notions
remains relevant whereas something like
South Park which
it's turnaround time being so short and
it could comment on stuff almost as it
happened becomes both a strength and a
weakness on a long enough time scale it
becomes a strength because they can
address things faster than any other
scripted show can and get on the ground
floor and get and get their thoughts and
their takes and their jokes out there
but on the flip side why would you go
back and re-watch it it's completely
dependent on the knowledge of this thing
that happened at this point in time and
if you don't have a particular
commitment to that specific thing the
episode's not going to hold much for you
uh
hey Vera should I uh buy dreams of fire
I mean
I'd like you to
Link in the description for where you
can get that
um I hope you'd like it I hope anybody
would like it I am I am plugging away at
the
um
at the audio at oh my God
at the audiobook I am working on it
regularly it is moving forward
probably still not ready until next year
realistically
have you ever gotten the appeal of
debate the more time goes on the more
I'm convinced it's useless theatricality
and little else I think that
there is value in knowing how to debate
in terms of having interactions with
people not that you should turn in every
interaction you have with people into a
debate that's not helpful but
understanding the core philosophy behind
it the methodology the thought process
and what makes what it takes to build a
good argument
I think those are all decent things I
think the debate structure within like a
high school or college setting can have
value especially when you have to debate
an assigned side you don't get to just
pick the side you already believe in you
have to learn how to defend something
that and which means that you have to
understand the thinking behind something
that you don't even necessarily agree
with I think that can be a very helpful
thing but the spectacle of debate the
idea of sitting down and having a debate
with somebody in order to prove a point
to the greater masses
yeah I know that's freaking useless it's
absolutely useless I have an entire
video on the Vera wild Channel talking
about why I do not do debates
in particular like in that case I'm
talking specifically about debates about
the validity of being trans or gender
fluid or any other thing that I identify
as
um but honestly at this point I expand
that out completely
in the in the landscape in which we
currently have it debates have very
little value or at least they do not
have value as debates they basically
only serve as a way to broadcast what
your views and thoughts are and then you
your opponent broadcast theirs and
audiences who are only passingly
familiar with either of you can hear
what you are saying but it's not a
debate it shouldn't be called a debate
because it does not resemble in any way
shape or form an actual debate what it
resembles is just
two Billboards placed alongside each
other and you pick which one you like
the messaging on more
uh
would HP ever return to your shelf if
she died or
went destitute and had been several
years
or she ever finally grew the F up
um
short version no
I mean so I'm gonna I'm gonna
deal with each of those three scenarios
differently because my opinion is
slightly different if she died no
no she dies tomorrow then she dies with
hate in her heart and it has still
tainted the books and the people who
continue to defend her forever for me no
impact she does not return to my shelf
if she has gone destitute and it's been
several years since then uh no I don't
really care how much money she has I
care about the things that she is saying
and the harm that is caused by them
whether or not she goes broke I might
get some shot and Freud out of that but
it wouldn't make me comfortable engaging
with her work again and your final
scenario if she finally grew the F up
presumably meaning she recognized the
harm that she's done and apologized for
it
whether or not I could ever engage with
Harry Potter again would 100 depend on
what steps she took to remedy the damage
she did and to be clear I don't think
she can in terms of how long she has
been doing this and the amount of
attention money and Prestige she is
granted to downright hateful harmful
ideas and people
all right
I do not believe
for me
that she can undo that
however
if she did come to recognize the damage
she caused
I would still hope to see her attempt to
undo it and not just go I was wrong and
stop tweeting that is not enough that
would have been enough
Maybe
in July of 2020.
it can't be now so whether or not I
would ever engage with her work again
would depend on whether or not she took
the effort and the time
to demonstrate
actively that she truly understood what
she did wrong
and that she spent years
decades
trying to remedy undo and correct that
prove to me that you didn't say I'm
sorry because you got tired of arguing
or because your publicist finally
convinced you you need to stop saying
these things
put your money where your mouth is
and even then I probably wouldn't engage
with it again although I might be more
forgiving of other people who do so or
at least put new money into it because
as I said people who have just been
holding on to you know the the stuff
they've already paid for it's your right
to do that just don't defend her just
don't do that don't do that
don't
I do need to wrap up soon got a few more
Super chats Dr lunar if Batman was real
but exactly as he is in the comics like
no killing gadgets The Works how much
does he affect things in the world
ah
none
I mean the thing to keep in mind is
the world he exists in is not the world
we exist in he exists excuse me in a
world of the Joker the penguin clay face
stupid hiccups um yes he exists in a
world of stupid hiccups
etc etc etc
but that's not the world we live in and
the world we live in
a
vigilante beating up random thugs
because that's who he'd be fighting
because we don't have super villains in
this world so what he'd be beating up is
poor people most of them probably uh
minorities so uh uh he doesn't affect
the war
the positive way
honestly even out of no killing rule
he'd just be a he would be
this is not me condemning the character
or the fiction or the escapism but if
Batman existed in the real world
he would simply be a non-lethal Kyle
ritten house
and we don't need that
[Music]
you know what I did but shouldn't have I
upped my patreon pledge six out to keep
him happy with me in the past I've spent
three thousand dollars in six months
police content creators are like no
now look as someone whose livelihood
depends on the support I get from
patreon do not spend more than you can
afford and don't spend it to try and
make us happy
spend what you are comfortable with and
what you feel we are worth if you can't
afford it
because again
he's probably not going to notice if you
up your pledge
or if you drop your pledge or if you
stop supporting him altogether
we do not take it personally I have
multiple people who I have to take off
and then put back on my end credits on a
semi-regular basis because they drop
support for whatever reason they can't
afford it this month or you know things
are stressed tighter they haven't been
watching my stuff lately but then they
come back again they're back in the
credits again
it's a flow it comes it goes no content
creator is so super focused on you in
specific that what you are talking about
doing is going to tip the scale one way
or the other I'm not saying that he
wouldn't be appreciative of it but it's
not going to change his opinion of you
because he is not focused on you to that
degree he just isn't and it's not
because he's like I don't care about you
people it's because
he's got other [__] to do
he's not hyper focused on you
he's not
I can guarantee that
Gwen Goodrich
oh first ever Super Chat much
appreciated message retracted so I don't
know what to say but thank you all the
same much appreciated
uh is it okay to ask your thoughts on
good omen season two and if you liked it
not in chat unfortunately
um again there'll be a video out
tomorrow kind of explaining where things
are right now with review content
because there's a little bit of an
update on that but no
um I will not be answering such
questions in uh in chats or on stream
uh
speaking of satisfire I've had this
debate before do you think satire is
more effective if it's broader or zeros
in on more specific topics I think it
ages better if it's broader that doesn't
necessarily mean it's more effective it
kind of depends on what you're trying to
do are you trying to satirize
like a person a moment or are you trying
to satirize a mode of thought a way of
being a more generalized thing because
there's validity in both but in terms of
Aging it's gonna age a lot better if you
go abroad generally
foreign
topic sex and gender and Star Trek
moderator Jesse gender that'd be
interesting
uh
uh all right I am gonna I'm gonna wrap
this up for the night probably my
favorite Spike moment so far is winning
offers to help Xander rescue Buffy and
Riley only to mention the regions and
why he usually wouldn't then just
buggers off
I like spike a lot like there's some
issues with Spike in um season
six
um but neither uh actor involved in that
scene thought it was a good idea or it
should have been done so I take some
comfort in that
I think my favorite Spike moment will
always be
um when Buffy says to him tell me what
you're doing here five words or less
out for a walk
[__]
ah
all right
that's gonna wrap it up today
thanks so much everybody uh uh I hope
that you have a um oh did I miss did I
miss something Annelise okay what do we
got uh starting College in person today
for the first time since covid can you
wish me good luck I can best of luck
annalize I hope College treats you well
and that you have a positive experience
with it
um apologies it's I I'm not I don't
always grab all the stuff that's going
on it's
it kind of comes and goes
uh both the chat and my attention ADHD
lovely uh thank you for catching me on
that Carolyn I appreciate it immensely
thank you everybody for tuning in I hope
you have a great rest of the day stuff
coming up new video tomorrow this
channel
um and it will be talking about
um some changes in my ability to talk
about
um movies I basically I heard back with
some further clarifications from sagafra
so I'm gonna update on that Saturday's
video kind of a follow-up to last
Saturday's video because I said I would
talk about some of the reasons I think
the studios in the executives are going
to lose in their fight with the Union so
I'll be talking about that on Saturday
tomorrow also twitch stream
um I think I'm gonna play Bastion
because I feel like some comfort gaming
thank you very much and that's what's
coming up in the immediate
I mean more twitch on Friday as well so
that uh that should do us
thank you everybody for joining me
um tomorrow's video is just gonna go
live there's not gonna be a Premiere
there will be a Live premiere for
Saturday's video so that should do it I
hope that you all have a great rest of
the day take care of yourselves and
remember
that you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
McCafferty